what's up people it's my channel now get
ready for the John show we're only gonna
talk about weird indie horror from now
on so your superhero [ __ ] it's not it's
not gonna happen it's not gonna happen
unless it's like you know the one or
couple that I take like a personal
interested just kidding that I love all
this stuff - you're just in a different
way
what's up Greg how's it going my guest
for today we're gonna get into the
acting method of Greg Alba what he does
to get in character as Greg Alba of
YouTube not just Greg Alba of life Greg
what's your favourite swearword I think
I'm just realizing this is a terrible
idea
fine we're gonna do a top 10 list live I
know anything can happen and by anything
I mean on popular opinions usually what
happens with the top 10 video is people
hate you for having a difference of
opinion because we should all be the
same but here's the thing is now we can
collect all that hate in real time that
and then forget about it as soon as the
live stream is done you know well the
fun part is half these of the live
streams just gonna be people for
requests to do reaction to videos hello
Kratos got a war and yeah hey look how
you guys doing it's our first video back
I know we put up something yesterday but
we just started filming again today John
was out of town that I was out of town
and I was like you know it would be fun
just to just kick off the new year with
a with a live stream with you guys and a
lot of people were asking for top ten
videos the best movies and stuff so I
thought all right we'll do the top ten
who's due alive you know well I put all
that editing in you know we're gonna do
it Bill O'Reilly is just so people so
let's uh let's check this out and then
you know after we're done doing the list
you know we'll look at some of you guys
were saying to us in the chat you know
maybe take some questions
yeah despot see ya dude John Campea
style yeah just super chata send now you
increase your odds of getting us to
answer a question huh if you super
channel I will literally
our opinion to your favorite movies yeah
if you pay enough I will just make old
my top 10 whatever you like you know
what's up baby
that that John Campea man mmm he's a
smart guy he's a really nice guy too
if you guys haven't seen my episode I
did on with him super super nice it's
Canadian makes sense yeah it's got a
good business going the John Campea show
that's cool man that could take some
notes you know we're doing a live stream
why don't we just make an announcement
and say we're just gonna copy John here
now on just live streams I just
announced that we're joining his channel
is like a featured you know personality
and then like start a rumor ourselves
then maybe always have to happen yes
yeah I already had you one I concur
John why is John wearing a Hitler shirt
I'm not it's that Groucho and I can flip
it because there's a quote from his
writings on it so no it's not Hitler I
don't love white supremacy or Nazis or
any of that [ __ ] you know okay you know
we but overlord was a bitchin movie you
know we could do is we could we'll put
whatever they want to and our number
four hang on how much they super chest
oh thanks hubby I messed with you too
hobby Brendon Barreto says John is gay
John we gotta do the list we do but but
a higher gain gayness all right let's do
list all right okay whoa the people are
giving you fashion advice now Liz I'm
nervous I'm nervous okay look so nobody
knew his countdown all right at number
10 we share this list so low a Star Wars
story oh definitely yeah that was
actually we stated special for the least
best but you know this the least best
but I mean when you switch directors
like that you think you're gonna get
like a totally inconsistent film but it
was cool if they actually managed to
really pull it off and Donald Glover is
great and I might say I prefer him over
Harrison Ford oh definitely and I mean
just the just the general like sepia
level of color that movie has yesterday
like that's what I want on a star was
something like really straightforward
and like not too unique in any way and
that's what I think so solo gave us
a pedestrian star wars and that's the
level I want to see it's after the last
Jedi I'm really relieved we got
something like solo star war story so
really put things back on trauma people
already disagreeing with us it's too bad
number nine Jurassic world falling
Kingdom you know after I saw Jurassic
world know : yeah I was I was a little
worried that we couldn't top Jurassic
world I wanted to whoo we did that
volcano sequence what love is how they
like grounded in reality you know and a
lot of people weren't on board for the
whole you know like having a home
invasion horror or taking cues from you
know the werewolf movies and stuff it
really reminded me of Joe Johnston's
yeah The Wolfman
so but then I found out there literally
shot that was actually the smartest
choice they've had since the first
Jurassic Park movie I would arguably say
that it's almost as good as the first
Jurassic Park yeah it's better than part
two yeah you know you think - some
people would be agreeing with us okay so
number a we have red Sparrow oh I loved
it uh after the work that director
French guy did with Jennifer Lawrence
and Hunger Games Movies I'm always
excited that are gonna reunite and boy
do they deliver
oh he's French I heard something else
like Gary roster Oh he directed the
first one but the guy who directed all
the other ones that or the last two or
something yeah so and I thought that
Jennifer Lawrence really nailed that
accent and I thought she did such a
great job you know like it's it's you
redefined the trope of woman has to get
assaulted in order to be a tough
character they made that work yeah more
than any better than the movie revenge
more than anything I feel like they took
their their sexual politics and really
earned every ounce of having them on so
yes by backing it up yes a kind of
commentary yes is what red Sparrow
definitely visually beautiful isn't just
exploited hey Justin this belt thank you
for agreeing with
choices okay politely thank you for not
even questioning because that's what we
want
okay so John watch somewhere number
seven choice our number seven choice is
Robin Hood who would have thought they
could do it dude Taron Egerton that's
like they needed this when I heard that
they were gonna Batman Begins this
little did I know dude slender day we're
gonna actually Batman Begins it's John
they really did you can't be distracted
when we're trying to give our our
mission to please I just I don't want
people disagree people please I don't
want people getting mad at I am a people
I am I don't I just I can't deal with
the negativity right now this that's
happening for so all right Robin she's
not already Robin Robin Hood
the action was great it reminded me of
the movie arrow meets them the show
arrow meets the movie 300 and when I
think so these really underrated since
the beginning of mythology and and you
know folktale people been waiting for a
modern badass take home yeah it's been
in in the age that it's set in for way
too and also the actor that everyone
like loves mmm-hmm and medicine he's
good isn't it - ben mendelsohn yeah
really killing it in that one role he
always plays in every movie now despite
his media is huge rainy talent I I think
it was a great idea that we that we
livestream our opinion I think instead
of really thinking this over because
think about it in a video people don't
have to watch the whole thing but in
lines mean they definitely do they're
gonna hear everything they have to say
before making your skin that way you can
be clear about why you like it it's
number six we have the Meg I don't nag
you for the best okay when you think I'm
gonna get some really can't be silly
really expensive like sci-fi channel
movie you get that but even more depth
in the movie which we really took me
back I was surprised when I think of
memorability I think of the main the meg
Meg easily way betters I mean I think it
deserves the top spot of number six here
it's just better the Jurassic world
falling yeah that's that's sane of what
is G action what's number five though by
golden rings that's Christmas five was
crazy because we didn't know this movie
was even coming out so like the day
before it came out
they dropped a trailer at Super Bowl and
then the trailer was like whoa what is
this
we got something even weirder and set
arranger and character defined the
Cloverfield paradox I walked in line to
hate this button but the opposite thing
is hard to the hard frustrating movie
you just can't say that it's frustrating
like it has so good so many cool weird
sci-fi Twilight Zone II elements that it
really really pays off all of I John and
it's right there with you yeah it gave
me faith that Cloverfield is a franchise
okay so how much super chat are we at
there people like a green like four
dollars now okay okay that's a good
that's a good sign
that's a good sign okay good all right
good it looks like some okay no one has
any of our movies on their list just as
we're - we'll definitely come out number
four lower this movie is like best
resembles us I didn't want to put this
too high on the list cuz just came out
and you need to let time pass but yeah
it's just like us and it's homes of
one's inner Moses the definitive version
of this movie the thing is like Benedict
Cumberbatch he thinks he can walk into
he thinks he can be Khan he thinks he's
a great anybody thinks he can be
Sherlock and he can't be anybody you
know like I thought it was gonna be hard
to outshine Robert Downey but you know
Will Ferrell man he's killing the game
now when I think of Sherlock Holmes
I think of Will Ferrell and intelligence
and intelligence it's the smartest movie
I've seen oh and when I think of Watson
I think of my girlfriend's cat name but
you think of him right after this i mean
john c reilly has had a killer here
oh yeah the sister brothers Ralph breaks
the internet no no it's it's stand but
to top it off none of it beats his
performance in Watson no nathan Hanson
thanks for the two bucks
to give you a spoiler Mission Impossible
may or may not be mentioned this is my
livestream personality November 3 you
think you'd be sick of why a novels but
it's really hard I'm once so I think
we're Hawaiian novel adaptations been
lately
yeah and then you hear Peter Jackson
back in the game
they make trailers and make it look like
Peter Jackson's directing but he's not
and then you watch the movie whoa it's
me like world building it's like Mad Max
as a city well we'll wait Peter Jackson
didn't direct this movie but it feels
like he did right I could have sworn
that he directed this movie
Wow is this a bit no yeah I thought the
facts were that directed mortal in oh
[ __ ] whoa whoa hold on we're getting
some super chats Joseph Joseph
misspelled you know are you related to
the director of Friday the 13th rich
reviews one of the worst films of the
year is Roma everyone should announced
that film you know what I gotta agree
yeah I got her agree oh I don't think
that that guy's got any artistic talent
I got our true and I think it should be
only seen on smaller than when I when
she first like what the [ __ ] why are
they putting his movie on Netflix this
is the kind reading you see in the
theaters then I saw it in the theaters
and then when I should have just watched
it some Netflix Matt yeah that was
something Niraj Krishnan we might
mention Hurricane hi-c a beautiful son
of a [ __ ] he's part of our patron page
to also thank you for tipping such a
weirdly specific amount well you know
from he's in New Jersey almost at indium
and that would mean to sound racist so
you don't want to do that in say it's
good that you avoided that number two
yeah okay so a couple years ago we got
this like prequels start of franchise to
the Harry Potter world called fantastic
beasts and where to find them and I was
on the spectrum of you know I like this
movie do I really want to see a
franchise
then they announced fantastic visa
crimes a Grindelwald starring none other
than the most beloved celebrity in the
world James got no Johnny Depp Johnny
Dow people love both people love both of
them equal equally I know I just can't
help but smile at the joy the world
gives and and so we we went to go watch
this movie definitely and the movie
starts it's great and then you know what
15 minutes later it gets evasion to be
what we were like I think this movie
could be doing yeah or honestly but but
as it stands it did more than any other
movie you might find like whoa there's a
lot of story here and they managed to
tell it all in such a cohesive
easy-to-follow and weirdly primarily
without exposition that's the thing is
all visual storytelling CD alike when
they put a hobbit in 48 frames and there
was so much more visual information it's
like take that but apply it to a script
man it's like every character is the
main character of their own movie that's
great see if we were recording this we
could have trimmed this down to at least
10 minutes mm-hmm all right so before we
unveil our number one pick hold on I
just thought of another one that we have
to mention the honorable mentions for oh
yes our number one pick for our favorite
movie of the year
well let's mention some honorable
mentions Slender Man for sure Slender
Man was a solid I always I thought it
was cool you know how infinity war used
trailer footage mm-hmm that does that in
the movie yeah I thought it was clever
yes Slender Man slender did that for
most of the movie yeah cinema right
there is they're gonna show you a
trailer complete actually that's not a
bad idea
show a trailer that's just like the
movie but it's not at all the movie mark
and there you go people are gonna be
total surprised and number three I feel
pretty I thought it was a good movie
about embodying being overweight and
truth or dare
this was the scariest movie blown houses
released and the smartest
you know the most unique yeah and plus
it stars Lucy Hale so listen I know
you're watching yeah I lost my train of
thought
hurricane heist hurricane eyes we
skipped number four we skip number four
hurricane heist race
our number one honorable mention is
Nutcracker in the four rounds loved it
if you think you've seen enough
Nutcracker you've not seen it like this
with Helen Mirren you that important
Freeman and there may not seen it
needlessly expands that's when you got a
real movie page Ostrom this fell six
bucks now sorry man damn that's cool
cool about you but I'm happier that to
know you
John I'm feeling like Jason Momoa about
an hour and a half and Aquaman I'm
losing my memory super Chad gets rich
reviews remind me that you asked this
question how do you pull up just a super
chat whatever sexy can you can you email
John Campea for me acting like your
music ask you how I do this maybe it's
in those three dots there's no click
that one John look sorry there's just
some conversations you shouldn't have
during a live stream okay so oh rich
reviews reminder you asked that question
you me just you write it down best sex
scene movie sack scene this year
okay so our number one pick our top ten
and if you're just now tuning in to the
live stream ask someone else to catch
you out there still tried donating just
God asking some new people just got in
alright let me just make break some
really good for you ten soloists are war
story is my number ten favorite movie
the year nine Jurassic world phone king
of hands down eight red sparrow not a
seven Robin Hood six the Meg five a
Cloverfield paradox for Holmes and
Watson three more legends two fantastic
beasts two and number one fifty Shades
freed also our best artists posted to
you in that movie blue someone away it
was you know you think that sexual
tension couldn't get any hotter wait
till you get
marry don't wear pants to that theater
cuz you're gonna need new ones at the
end you know amen to that and it doesn't
matter who you go with the people behind
me were like an older mother and her
younger but still kind of older son it
was a very diverse crowd it reaches all
peoples with us message of sex other
than when people were laughing during
the movie intentionally might I add
because they harness the powers Oh flora
comedy mmm-hmm
the theater was silent no other silent
movie experience by a crowd huh there's
been a quiet place but that wasn't even
as quiet as this one when they go into
the play room you know why and drop
invested and it has a rewarding ending
okay Clyde don't miss the client now
that you guys have spent almost 20
minutes with us in this livestream
yourself go thank you thank you
oh [ __ ] John do we read the wrong oh no
what did we do whatever you put in front
of us we're gonna Rio the [ __ ] yourself
San Diego we found the real list so we
found the real list and what do you know
you have ten and I have Oh why they're
different we know what you know how it's
funny about that John and I started off
saying we gotta act like we're super
serious and then I think right we start
her like there's no way we have to be
serious I think as long as we just
commit to the joke yeah okay Amy O'Neil
says she loves you
oh I love you too I gotta tell her she
loves what are you gonna show earlier on
in the chat cuz I you know I was looking
and she said she loved us both but I
guess she loves me slightly more than
you wow I haven't had enough of that
this week sorry
all right look we're gonna go through
our actual number ten we won't spend as
much time we're gonna we're gonna dish
these out for you guys rich reviews this
Lucy Hale need to get a better agent I
think her agent is doing just fine
I saw her hosting that New Year's thing
and she looks great and she looks happy
and people always present them best
selves online or on television don't
forget these words most also it's really
hard and and your s your other question
best sex scene in a movie it was with
Ethan Hawke and Angelina Jolie and
taking lives because I did not know that
scene was gonna happen at my teenage
year I watched it and sure enough my mom
sitting right next to me so oh boy what
a king lives all right guys here we go
nine Number ten pick for my favorite
film of the year this is my intellect
picked this is my pick where I'm like
this is the one that's mainly coming
from the mind and less from the is
weirdly there's other movies that I was
like I really just feel a lot more for
that are gonna be my honorable mentions
but this one was like I gotta have at
least one of these beaches solely for
that purpose and it was bad times at the
El Royale thought look I really want to
see all these movies that I'm not the
list we have movie reviews for already
on the internet that you can go watch so
I'm not gonna break that's why I kind of
find it funny when people try to re
review them again yeah so yeah I'm a
really different colorful Colorado
you're gonna get blocked right now cuz
this is many a time the thing is
colorful Colorado is usually very
supportive and it's this one issue that
that we cannot seem to talk sense into
him why I don't know why I don't know
why do grip I John it's about to get
really you want it's dirty it's about to
get there you know channel with no grip
all you need to do is get offended that
would be then you get a real Greg in
here that's what's to you you're gonna
enter your M&MS favor your main source
of creative inspiration is just having
to prove that you're the best that's
where most of my life is alright so yeah
bad sounds the Oh Roy yeah I thought was
written wonderfully and was that's for
some reason even though I didn't love it
it's
with me and I like a film that like
sticks with you where you just keep
looking back on it yeah keep going yeah
this was kind of cool what they did a
film that grows on you over time and the
performant chris hemsworth it was like
one of the scariest things all year that
I've seen no isn't that movie really oh
yeah man I would say I would say bad
times Dale where I was I was really if
you could really feel the character
history and I loved good character I
feel like that's the way I that's my
favorite way to approach any top-10 this
whole this whole chance becoming about
how everyone loves you more you know
what John you just do the top 10 list
from now oh you just saw the real Greg
oh look out oh well okay well my number
one is some very cerebral [ __ ] I
don't know it's it's just not the same
without Greg see now that there's a void
here that happened and all I'm thinking
about is how all of my top tens are just
Greg in all of our various sketches
that's my that's my number 10 pick is
our infinity war sketch because Greg is
was so committed to it and he's so
sincere and even though he's happy at
first that I'm getting dusted you know
he does cry for me and that 50 percent
love right there I really think was the
most touching thing I felt though yees
number 10 is our inventory sketch number
nine is our fall out and I just a
possible fall ask you know what I don't
need anyone's approval Wow confidence
I'm here no matter what even if you hate
me I'm here dude all that Greg love but
look now there's so much Greg love in
that oh you got Greg is hotter that's
even better
who said that boo boo boo boo vanilla
was my girlfriend I like you both
because that counter Greg should run for
has you even better grab him by the
[ __ ] I decided when I first arranged
just all of my pics I I don't love
putting things in order favorite loss so
I initially put them in a few like you
get all the sex appeal you know you are
I'm a fluffy twig person who in 2019
hopes to put some muscles on this
but for right now you're way sexier than
me especially in that department I
originally organized these by date of
release because that's easier to me than
ranking them in terms of favoritism but
to put them in a 10 I went with the most
recent release laughs because I feel
like that's fair and it's spider-man
into the spider verse because that movie
especially for the animated flicks of
the year and the superhero flicks of the
year I found so enjoyable and so
creative and visually groundbreaking
like that movie fired on every cylinder
for me and that's what I wish that so
many more comic book films in general
would embrace is you know that instead
of trying to bring all of the physics
down to earth let's go out there and
let's get you know sci-fi about it and I
love the personality of the movie the
look of the movie like that's the most
dazzled and just effortlessly joyous I
think I've been during a superhero movie
this year so uh spider-man into the
spider-verse
only ten because they're you nothing
that much I'm confident about that pick
cuz you didn't look at them once while
you were saying to get on a roll I just
looked wherever I needed to look I mean
John yes
that's why the ladies love you man look
number nine all right number John you
can't leave the bags I feel alright
number nine is a movie that I haven't
seen anyone's top ten list
I saw JT's I don't know if anyone's put
this on their top ten list but you know
what [ __ ] it I love it more than the
first one
I got Deadpool - okay that's my opinion
great right think no one's getting mad
at me hey thank God because my emotions
are determined by people's opinions oh
definitely please John always my number
nine yeah okay I'm not many reviewing
these oh I'm just gonna be I gave you
blunt feedback on these number nine I
put American animals I don't necessarily
think it's a perfect movie I think it's
kind of a you know you could debate it
for multiple angles but it was one of
the most you
Niq and memorable movies I saw a year so
hell yeah
and also that finale half an island I'll
tell you John yeah it's a mesh of genres
I look I think we got to just you know
stick to this like real live stream
movie news people who wear beanies and
Hitler shirts Hitler my number eight
pick is actually the movie overlord if
you had enough of horror during your
October season
well don't worry a week later there was
another treat for you that movie really
really stuck with me man one of the
nicest surprises
that was a surprise film I was wildly
impressed with how that all went down
because you do start off for just this
like whoa this is like the horrors of
World War two yeah the zombie shits like
barely in there but the movies engaging
and [ __ ] well acted dude well acted
and the effects had some genuine like
there's I don't know you seem like a
stickler for body horror too huh I love
some good I love some good body horror
and there's some good body horror
movements also done with some CGI and
usually any body horror CGI is like
whatever yeah they're moser or the whole
crowd including myself like oh whatever
their budget was that movie had a good
mixture of CG and practical work didn't
always you know 100% measured but they
knew workable yeah and uh fun fact oh I
forgot about the ACS choice oh damn I
see okay for the very end of this
broadcast I came up with a couple like
not rankings but just like a little
Awards you know kind of like the Oscars
do where it's like here's a you know
Lifetime Achievement yeah so uh was you
maybe maybe yeah go John um actually fun
fact both Deadpool 2 and Overlord almost
made my 10 so there you go Wow I read is
a fact of you said nobody nobody was
cool to why almost number 8 for me
though I'm gonna go with hereditary not
a movie that I loved every choice they
made but it's one of the most memorable
and one of the most intense film going
experiences I've had
was a very physical movie to watch thank
you Chris hope he loves both John
Humphrey and Ryan Wright equally he'd
clearly was both equally us both equally
thanks Chris Cole thanks Chris yeah
that's a movie word just like that every
everything is so crafted and so well
realized that even if I didn't
necessarily love every choice that it
made it it just a wrench to my jaw open
at one point harder than any movie I saw
this year Toni Collette is definitely
getting snuff did all these Oscar things
or these awards things and yeah it's one
of those movies where I'm like I don't
care really what my opinion is about the
plot I just I really do appreciate what
she did here is every fun funnier than
Unix so fun so fun hilarious black comm
that's that's the hereditary impression
right there definitely that's the
impression no no someone says oh no I
had to play a game of charades where I
can't speak yes I'm gonna guess the
reddit area I would I do that bit sorry
impression is this what I would think of
the conjuring oh I thought we were doing
a joke bit and then I went for Bird box
does everybody be talking about that
bird box
okay guys number seven is the feel-good
movie of the year for me I fell in love
with this movie it just really touched
my heart and as a man who recently did a
DNA ancestry results test and found out
I am primarily of Asian descent crazy
rich Asians makes it on the list 100
down I actually when I heard they're
making a sequel I said I could step back
into this movie yeah I love that oh yeah
what's the quitting that made me so
happy it was it was that if there's any
movie on this list that just like I was
really happy for like 99 percent of that
movie even when it's terrible for her in
that film and there's a dead fish on her
bed I'm happy for her yeah true that my
friend true that now number 7 for me
iiiiii I wonder I don't know if we're
gonna come into some overlap but number
7 for me is mr. Thomas the cruise in his
action opus of the year definitely one
of the most spectacular
and just gripping a physical level did
the mummy came out last year hey hey but
it's still one of my favorite movies
since then you know especially with the
way that Jake Johnson you know like Jake
Johnson killing it anyway
hello Mission Impossible fall out Baby
Cakes I mean it's one of the yeah just
like one of the most crafted it's the it
is I get why people call it the Mad Max
this year they're not alike very much
but they are just tangible in such a
satisfying way and also even though I
mean some of the finer details of
Mission Impossible movies they don't
really keep great track of it is one of
their most solid and like fleshed out
adventures and if it's not my favorite
of the series it's up there because it
was just such a great time and I have a
sentimental attachment cos of our sketch
I feel like I should do my number-6
first Wow alright now number six is also
crazy adjacent because I kind of agree
with everything you just said like of
all the movies I saw this year it made
me perhaps just the most joyous yeah and
I love a movie that takes me to just
sort of a different culture for a while
like the same like Greek Wedding kinda
does I feel like crazy which age is
almost even more does that crazy which
age that's my roommate they're all gonna
be wicked I think that we should have
done like 10 10 honorable mention
10 10 my number six movies upgrade yo
upgrade discount Tom Hardy am i right no
I want to take the opportunity to talk
about this really quick earlier today
John and I got into a discussion about
how much we hate that people say Logan
Marshall greatest go discount Tom Hardy
I feel like that really takes away a lot
of praise and a lot of actual
acknowledgement of his talent and who he
is because he is such an amazing actor
that was like dude I'm like that does
not mean he's any less talented and it
just sounds that way and it attaches his
identity to another actor and just makes
people think of Tom Hardy and it's like
you know you can
lmg at least reiated but low commercial
green hell yeah
I love negative comments like colourful
colorado's of like no hate here dude
just honesty when you say something mean
you know attack that logically makes
zero sense
so yeah upgrade was I think Logan
Marshburn is amazing the action that
film man that like that's like
redefining some action sequences you
know now and now every time I see a
[ __ ] like punch and then the camera
moves with a punch I'm like you know
what else that was also that was also
and hey that guy I love your comment he
maybe discounts on part of a venom was
discount of crazy oh that is good it's a
good way to come back man I talking
about
it's like ah yeah it's like and also
know that was the one movie this year
that other than like infinity war that
really made me like audibly participate
with a crowd just because I yeah really
gets you going yeah yeah so easy like
cheering and [ __ ] and clapping like say
all that [ __ ] like that that film really
had me going there yeah my number 5 why
don't be a movie we start really early
this year but I very much appreciate it
and is taking my like out there slot and
that is my elation Alex Garland's right
I'm directing sophomore effort uh-huh
it's really weird it's not a
crowd-pleaser or anything like that but
I really appreciate that somebody
decided to fund that kind of sci-fi I
wish there was more of that kind of
sci-fi I think that movie handles what
it is really well and it manages to
paint a hard to decipher in there
metaphor in a way that you could
actually decode which i think is hard a
lot of movies can hide behind just be so
obtuse that who knows but I feel like
you could draw some compelling theories
out of annihilation there's a lot of
great work on screen design wise acting
wise writing directing all that stuff
it's great
I'm right there with you John Jason
Dolan my friend dolan what's up buddy
that's perfect because I was gonna ask
you my friend if I could borrow $2 so
thank you I'm always happy when I see
your name man you know it's funny I
forgot there were some movies we didn't
review and I feel like I have to swap
out one of my top five oh yeah oh well
please hey man anything can happen we
said this at the top that's why do you
think man good no that's why it's better
to film these because opinions can be
subject to change definitely even by the
minute yeah they can remember that that
top 10 yeah before that's my favorites
now if you declare a movie as your
favorite movie ever that can never
change you know okay for my number five
I have a Spider Man into the
spider-verse this was the only film
that's like there are movies that I
bought tickets for like twice in advance
like infinity war I was already
scheduled to go twice Aquaman I was
scheduled to go twice like I already had
booked yeah but but into the
spider-verse was the one movie I saw
this year where I watched it and
literally right after I went on my phone
and got tickets right away to go see it
again I just knew I had to watch it
again
yeah and it's it's um I noticed that the
first time I watch it I was just purely
dazzled and the second time I watched it
I felt like I was more emotional towards
a lot of things that actually occur with
Miles Morales in that movie like I
because before you're taking in so much
but in this but the second time around I
got a little misty at a couple points so
that I would say it's a de spider-verse
man as a fan what an achievement I
haven't gotten to see it again but that
is of all these movies that is one that
I definitely want to try and see again
for its especially in the theaters yeah
yeah that just feels like a special yeah
for some reason number four for me
number four I I yeah we did the switch
that's why okay number four on my list
is one of the weirder movies that I've
seen this year but I really appreciate
it it's just sort of like you know a new
director's vision and also that had a
lot
it's mine and that was sorry to bother
you which I saw very late in the game
and there are a number of like I didn't
get to see all the things I want to see
it's here by far and there are a number
of movies in this vein that I missed out
on too so I don't know what might happen
if I see more of last year's movies but
this movie left a big impression on me I
mean I'm a big fan of the key stamp
field anyway so I'm psyched that he got
the star in a movie full out I really
like how surreal and strange and dark
the comedy is and I like the magic
realism again it's just another one of
those movies that I really appreciate it
both for just the fact that somebody
decided to let this get made because I
don't see things like this very often
and I thought that it managed to take a
socially relevant idea and make it part
of a story in a way that you can draw
like an actual real-life application
from but that doesn't feel like the
whole time it's trying to jam down my
throat like it's trying to tell me
something I feel like it really is like
a piece of art that has a consciousness
on its mind and I appreciate that about
it so yeah my number four is Avengers
infinity war whew
I saw three times the theaters it's
going on this list and on number three
my number three is as your number six
I'm going with upgrade which is one of
the most fun and satisfying movie
experiences this year for me we got to
go to the premiere was super awesome
we met LMG even and that was one of
those movies every I don't get excited
as much as I want to because it's hard
to do that nowadays because a lot of
things are made to look as cool as
possible and can be very disappointing
and you know I'm a big fan of Leigh
Whannell and I was rooting for him and
this was one of those movies where I was
like you know I'm just gonna let myself
be excited and hope that it works out
and it worked out and I just had such a
great time watching that movie and yeah
it's [ __ ] awesome like it's it's nice
to see some cyberpunk and the action is
like top-notch and Logan Marshall Greene
like I've been a fan of that guy for a
long time since devil actually since I
first saw that movie and I'm glad that
he's finally getting some more
recognition because once you're number
three Gregory this whole like movie
review thing really you think I should
try it no that guy
I probably would fail I probably would
oh man I don't know how to form opinion
my number three pick is Mission
Impossible fall out you know why it's my
number three pick this is the coolest
action movie all year I got all the
action movies this is the one dude
admittedly the only disappointing thing
about it was I thought Henry Cavill be a
little cooler right totally other than
that the movie hits every Mart ever like
to be dazzled by practical studs that
have such emotional intensity to every
single act like that's a long movie yeah
fallout is a long movie it's not hard
when I see that link it's a turn-off
then you watch it and it's not just oh
there's just so much action it's fun
because there's so much action in it
it's emotionally engaging throughout man
and it is tense and it's the only other
it's like it's so hard to have me going
to franchise this deep in and go oh [ __ ]
good job making seem dying I really dug
that film a lot you know I thought Henry
Cavill was good in it he just thought
you might have been a little like cooler
over character but I thought he was good
and that's not all on him either because
I feel like if the advertising hadn't
blown that we might have seen that
character differently yeah you just
think about things I'm like what are
some of the coolest things you've seen
all year when Tom Cruise ran again with
a broken ankle Tom Cruise flying a
[ __ ] real helicopter Tom Cruise on a
motorcycle Tom Cruise jumping out of a
plane yeah the bathroom fight is so many
funny like there's so many things in
that film and that film gave us the fist
like no matter what camel the fist
confident I will say all out is the best
trailer of the year only because of that
one moment because the second henry
cavill combined with sound effects
cocked his [ __ ] our pocket that shows
up what yeah that's when he cocked his
arms yeah that made everyone go the
mustache was worth it yes
this whole movie is oh yes that is the
best trailer of the year and in [ __ ]
lives up when you watch that movie man
that was that was just such a cool movie
really tense and oh yeah and you here's
doing another one like yeah hell yeah
that's that's what I am gonna be sad
when they but number two when he came
when he can't at least yeah yeah
number two for me I do i deliberated
over this whole list but number two for
me was a movie I saw not too too long
ago and that was just a little thing but
that really impressed me and really
stuck with me and it sort of centered
around just a world we don't ever really
get to look at in now times or any other
times and that was a movie called cam
which once Netflix I just threw it on on
a whim one night yeah and it's such a
fraught weird thriller that really just
is nifty and works and it shot really
well and it's you know like an actual
can girl wrote it so it has like this
very knowing like it is like watching
the lifestyle of somebody but also with
this weird thriller also happening
through it so you're getting kind of two
experiences at once and I just thought
it was really creative how they handled
it and the lead actress does a terrific
job I don't know he I was it was one of
the more pleasant surprises I had this
year and since I saw it it really stuck
with me yeah I've heard a lot of good
things about it
hi Lena and I participate in webcam
chats quite often do you make a lot of I
make a lot it
yeah I'm this to entertain never let me
it's all that's all obese men who want
to look at me
oh yeah well hey I mean you know you're
finding a valuable yes it was like women
no oh gosh she would not allow that huge
queue be pissed
so you're on like the grinder of
campsites yeah oh yeah only obese men
can look at me I just want to know what
that say it's cold but don't say it cuz
you don't want you boys hell yeah
alright my number two [ __ ] man don't
want to switch this around
you know what okay as long as you switch
it before you say what you're my number
two
yeah you know what I'm gonna say Black
Panther yeah yeah yeah you see as we
were doing this two movies came up that
I totally forgot about but and I'm like
oh [ __ ] I don't forget about them and it
was bumblebee in black Klansmen oh yeah
yeah and then I had this like wanted to
see black weird it's not where I was
like well maybe I'll switch black
panther with black Klansmen I'm like
what if I say that is it just sound like
I'm just taking like black movies and
switching them around and then I'm like
is that a weird thing to do that sounds
strange
maybe me just talking about it sound
strange I don't know if somebody in the
comments is more enlightened than we are
that's why I'm changing my pic to blind
spot II know I I did like what I love
Black Panther I did that was a to me a
lot of very culturally important movies
there's a lot of very important films
that do not come in the form of
blockbusters people and I thought Black
Panther really nailed it you know yeah
as a man who is from Africa himself to
me you know really Lima you watch my DSS
your results you know I am like point
zero one percent African so I I have a
lot of pride
that's why crazy rich Asians is my
number one I changed yeah I thought I
thought Black Panther that's one of the
movies I saw twice I was like I have to
see this movie twice yeah and it I'm a
sucker you know what I am I'm a sucker
for a movie that does variety well you
know like there are some movies that are
very contained and very specific and yet
sometimes those are the the crowning
achievements in my eyes that year but
then every once in a while I get a movie
like like we're talking about the matrix
for a long time beforehand and I don't
think my fans
but I would but the way how the matrix
does so much variety so well yeah where
it's like you're able to tell just a
cohesive strong character story good
villains eiei out a good plot but then
also have like a lot more nuance to it
to just that and symbolism and whatnot
so yeah I was a big I really loved that
movie
it really moved me a lot and I every
time I'm saying I cry wouldn't kill
mongers giving this final speech oh yeah
I want yeah this is actually a perfect
segue because I get the sense that there
are at least a couple movies that you
debated about and actually I I have some
honorable mentions prepared and perhaps
my biggest honorable mention is black
panther because that's a movie I really
know and really appreciate it and I
again yeah I kind of agree with you I
love the idea that you could have this
blockbuster that's totally satisfying
all the ways a blockbuster is but that's
also super cultural and that doesn't
have to just be white people and yeah I
really appreciate it and I movie really
stuff but oh don't get me wrong Andy
Serkis and Martin Friedman words the
best parts
I love a clock but yeah the best the
best 100 the standouts yeah whenever
they cut skill monger I'm like oh could
is whining
where's Martin freedom yeah yeah exactly
that's who we really made but yeah like
I had there definitely made and then
brothers a guy named John Reese
upsetting people in the comments because
he keeps asking us to react to this fan
film called Marvel Knights Spider Man
Marvel Knights Myron and I've seen a lot
of requests for the PewDiePie rewind for
this year know PewDiePie doesn't like us
yeah he I figured just by saying that
that might make PewDiePie aware of who
we are yeah it's gonna be like like it's
gonna be like heard you hate is gonna be
like I don't even know who the [ __ ]
you're talking about
no no I got my attend perfectly nailed
them with no contemplation whatsoever
okay I got ya I got black Klansmen man
that that film film haunted me haunted
like that is when Spike Lee I was a Stan
Lee
when Spike Lee wants to you know get a
political message across or something
like that push a certain agenda or
whatever he'll commit to it and I
thought black Klansmen even though I
heard a lot of the facts were really
miss told John what you're doing can I
you know it's distracting thing he is
opening like sixteen different windows
at Supercat so I want to make sure that
we can see thank you rich reviews I want
us to be able to see the channel three
screens here work up the goal was to
gear list back in front and the super
chat on the side and then I didn't
realize that your was the window and
then the other window was also your list
and it wasn't it was just a mess sorry
yeah we'll go watch black Klansmen guys
everyone's great a quiet place was
definitely one that's what I mine I
debated putting on yeah I list list and
I really appreciate it I was really
impressed by it I don't necessarily like
love it as much as I did at the time but
I still think that it's every bit as
good as I originally did I really
appreciate that I would also say quiet
place yeah you know bumblebee I feel bad
for not even considering it bumblebee
gets my most improved French I know what
I'm gonna switch out I really do
I might you know yeah yeah that's right
I like blockbusters because those are
the main things I have to watch to keep
up with her views on the channel no I'd
really enjoyed I appreciate it more you
awesome this Bell you rocked yeah
jaw else you got buddy oh she's out
alright alright you know I might just go
infinity war definitely one of the most
influential movies of this year
definitely really appreciate it it just
didn't make what's in
Deadpool 2 as well same thing
Incredibles 2 so you just like hate
comic book movies they're just not my
favorites that's all yeah I really
enjoyed all those incredible suits one
of my honorable mentions as well and
that one was this struggle and that
movie helped me even further appreciate
the original so like I really
yeah we like Christopher Robin
Christopher Robin's on my list a lot of
people who do like what I did I loved it
I loved it
overlord a green book is the movie I
thought was really charming really
delightful it reviewer yeah if you're
already aware to a certain degree it
might be kind of redundant free but
overall it's really heartwarming really
fun and the last one I think I had was a
star is born what
yeah that's your honorable mention well
I only got one more spot you know and I
thought that's probably my top honorable
mention because that's probably like
want it I almost had it on my 10th and
that it didn't make it
wait enough but Halloween on their
Halloween gets my Lifetime Achievement
Award I thought Halloween was was really
good unit of what I don't know because
they were awards I I came up with a
couple movies that I really appreciate
decisions John I'm having fun with your
movies I realize I have fun first man
youtuber rillette it we can't just have
fun first man's not one of my favorite
movies you're serious business one of
the most memorable visual experiences I
had all year so I want a name check it
somehow get creative alright well their
portrayal of space travel I thought was
very potent hey man dude good for you
memorably oh yeah my ships
yeah grandma got Ralph breaks the
internet and American animals hereditary
as an honorable mention there you go
okay guys listen my number once it stars
who is like I figured this some of our
list would overlap and stars born almost
made my list I was like you know what
I'll just chime it with you yeah a star
is born
that movie moved me to tears like four
different times for four different
reasons like Dan I was like a grieving
experience like Shakespeare like to work
in comedies and tragedies this movie is
not comedy but like love and tragedy is
like that movie yeah oh yeah and excited
with great
freaking music originally composed for
this movie
and just throughout like wow the whole
point of a movie is to move you and
without a doubt the movie the movie that
just moved me the entire time was a star
was born just in all different
directions was intimate and and yeah
heart-wrenching movies you got at best
tears ha best crying moan from Sam
Elliot oh you know why because you know
real tears are in most men's lives and
maybe that probably I can't speak for
women but maybe oh sure you can
for men really like a thing is like for
men who have a hard time crying yeah
there's the mark of true good acting
tears Sam Elliot is he's trying not to
cry you know he struck me like I've
heard you you mentioned that before and
it stuck with me oh really the idea that
yeah like some of the most crimes and
you're trying not to yeah it depends on
the tears yeah yeah well yeah Chino and
Godfather 3 when he's [ __ ] bawling at
the finale over the death of someone
very important yeah that's all I imagine
that's a hard place to get to because
you have to get to the point where you
are
put you're trying it's so built up
internally that it's it's trying to come
and you gotta fight it like that's
that's [ __ ] emotion right yeah yeah
that's what ii would say because we are
crying my number one pick of the year is
also a love story and the tragedy but
there's revenge in it too and I went
with Mandy cuz that's a John choice
that's your number one pick I didn't
realize you you loved it yeah man I
thought you just remember because we
were watching like
yeah well okay I don't know cuz I get
very self-aware and so in especially
moments like that when I know things are
tailored to me I'm like okay I want to
make sure I think about this because I
know that this is gonna be easy for me
to like and not think about and just the
more I thought about it the more it has
stuck with me and I really appreciate
what that movie is because in the time
of 80s nostalgia like it's very 80s
movie in a lot of ways but it doesn't
feel like it's aping [ __ ] left and right
true like any of the other stuff I've
seen this year yeah is when I think back
on it I'm like weirdly one of the
biggest flavors I remember is that it's
a love story it's a really heartbroken
fucked-up love story but it's like the
core is their love and I really felt
that throughout the movie and also it's
a visual splendor it's it's dark and
crazy and weird and it's a mishmash of
genres and it's a movie that only this
bunch of people could have ever made
like it's it feels like it fell out of
the wrong time and it's yeah it's just
one of the most unique and compelling
movies that's all we were having a talk
earlier about a lot of the differences
between style choice between matrix 1
and Matrix Reloaded and also the
influence of action movies after the
matrix and the thing I rewatched the
matrix again yesterday and I noticed
that the style a lot of times
complements and is seems so intentional
and purposeful and I think a lot of the
times with these 80s nostalgia kind of
throwback movies they get so caught up
in replicating an aesthetic yeah you
know like or oh this is a grindhouse
film Andy let's just throw a bunch of
scratches in there you know and here's a
bunch of things like like one thing that
kind of detracted from bumblebee was
like a lot and I'm like thank you
they're watching house you know and when
the thing about Mandy is its whole
aesthetic in style I never get pulled
out once going oh it's kind of look at
in a teaser right yeah like it feels so
intentional with the best way to tell
this story like the shots the colors the
film grain even like all that is all all
in tune with complementing the story
not just cool you know it's like after
the matrix you get a lot of action
movies it's a lot of the cool yeah it
doesn't really do anything there with
the emotions of the story yeah work
whereas Mandy's like it seems to bring
out the harrowing aspects of what red
red red red is going through in that
movie so yeah I would say it's one of
those I would say that movie for sure
yeah that's one of those movies that
just when I think of it I feel like it
just has its own quintessential quality
about it yeah yeah and yeah even though
I was you know kind of managed in my
emotions afterwards like I just really
loved that movie and I got to see it
twice actually this year in the theaters
so I'm I'm v8 theatres so yeah that that
movie really impacted me alright guys
well there's our top ten lists we're
gonna wrap this up in about a minute and
a half speed around time they're there
any questions we missed from the super
chat oh yeah there was a there were a
couple good ones that I saw somebody
asked what film did you think would suck
but turned out good like oh I don't
think it was like it hit me uh before
the reaction to when we did when we saw
the clip where were vans like smashing
up people before that I admitted that I
was like thinking about him in thinking
that he was probably bad like like it
just not like a good way at all and then
then we saw the clip and started winning
me over but I was still having like I'm
not sure yet and then I and then I
watched it and I was like you know some
of this is so bad it's good some of this
is just good you know like I'm either
way I'm really enjoying myself
yeah I would say venom was surprisingly
the next surprise for me whoa Eric
Horstmann hey buddy hey buddy damn
thanks buddy
all just to say that we'll take very
much hair course Minh is one of our top
pledges over at patreon people and
beyond that though this guy and I have a
lot of really engaging conversations
back and forth all the time he's a funny
guy
got a dark sense of humor sometimes just
a dirt
but the same time he's a guy with a
really good heart let me give a
interesting kind
oh yeah oh yeah they're a course they
love and yeah and uh oh and just there's
one more question yeah just what didn't
we get to see what we really wanted to
oh god I love this question
welcome to Marwan half of the movies on
the worst of list no just what didn't
you get to see that you're not used to
doing live streams and actually seen the
questions yeah yeah yeah so what
yeah oh I didn't see revenge I'm really
bummed I haven't seen revenge yet heythe
great John and I were just talking about
going to get and the documentary that
I'm committed to why they're two
documentaries I really want to watch I
really do want to see three identical
strangers because I was at Denny's with
milady last night and I was like there's
comercio that's your video watch right
and I was like what was one about the
triplets and then she went three
identical strangers don't oh that's a
good time just the cleverness of that
title because I go triplets and then
when you break it apart like but why are
they strangers Tina that's really
intriguing you know that and know what
should be my neighbor
my dad was the other one yeah I had
tickets I write already go or didn't you
didn't you have tickets you good to go
yeah ever sir might say I feel like we
both had plans to you know something
something happen I think somebody came
up for us yeah yeah the 8th grade black
Klansmen I want to see at blind spotting
I've heard so much great Jay Z's
favorite movie the inner splines but
yeah and I wanted to really want I saw
the trailer yeah me too damn like people
talk about how it's funny yeah where's
the funny in the burgundy yeah I feel
like that's gonna be one of those like
sleeper super unique movies that you
thought was straightforward I I really I
I'm pretty curious to go check out the
house that Jack built
I'm always like his movies are so
divisive
always found even though I know I'm
gonna go from very intrigued to
incredibly bored it's a very Lars von
Trier movie for me I was weird
interesting oh my god the entering and
boring pretentious buzzes that's a
graphic moment Suspiria was one Speed
Graphic spirit insane and that I really
really wanted to see and it was one of
those rows like it's almost a three-hour
movie I don't know what else Cui's this
scene especially if we're not gonna
review it hey Amy
oh yeah that's a great that's actually a
fantastic fantastic that's a great
suggestion for discussion video list of
fills of people are surprised they
haven't seen but have no interest to see
I'm not gonna list them right now oh
that's fast people will be dicks and I
very fortunate that there are some films
I haven't seen yet that I should have
seen by now that I haven't got why
haven't you seen it so would ruin it for
me in high school
you know what's funny usually they were
gonna go usually um I noticed that when
people with comedies especially yeah
what people say dudes
Tony your bread you totally you feel
yeah they go they show it to me that I'm
like nine times out of ten a comedy
cringe guy don't worry now I see where
what they were getting at or usually
just like well the thing is a lot of
time my humor is is I'm being it's like
if I do like curved humor or stoner
humor or whatever a lot of time I'm very
I'm kind of mocking it a little bit you
know oh yeah
so if you actually show me Super
Troopers and and I'm like you know I'm
not this weirdly in comedies I'm not a
big fan of that kind of thing it's you
know humor is a weird thing because
there's humor I like to engage it in
person that I just don't necessarily
like to watch as a movie yeah or or
watches a feature-length movie too
because like your sense of humor versus
what you would want to watch for
ninety minutes can be different yeah
true and uh yeah Super Troopers I I
laughed through but didn't really care
yeah is one especially that like the one
that's I feel like I know like stoner
comedies especially to me it's pineapple
express because I've seen half-baked and
how Hollies have things and I like
smiley face I'm okay I haven't seen so
I'm okay with a but but the thing is
freaking pineapple Express to me I'm
like you think you're walking it just
does some stoner comedy you pretended to
be coming like a really well done movie
half-baked you're like this is a stoner
comedy and I feel like stoners probably
made it whereas pineapple express you're
like a lot of stores worked on this and
don't think the guy who directed this
was high yeah such a kinetic movies
doing so many things yeah that's clever
and as well and like it's witty and as
it as a heart to it I don't think you
have to be a starter to like like if
anything Harold and Kumar hits that mark
a little bit better just being like a
full-out raunch
yeah vulgar movie and succeeding and
doing it yeah yeah yeah it's the first
although Christmas vacation really hit
the mark for me yeah that's a movie
people said I was like and then I
watched it and I'm like yeah I love this
that's my gross that movie kind of I saw
for the first time a couple years ago
and that was actually a movie where I
was like I know people love this I'm not
really I could not I don't care really
if I see it or not then I saw it I was
like oh yeah this is pretty fun yeah so
alright guys well thanks for watching us
thanks for sticking around for all the
meandering points forever stuck here
this long happy 29 years has been here
since the beginning of his lives from
anyone who's getting at that watch time
he was going and out Greg I acknowledge
cringe guy and he totally missed it dude
John Riis this is wait is this the first
time I'm seeing this comment it does
react to the spider-man fans never no
one's mentioned it
oh hey Laneige Lynnae John Reese amy
O'Neil that guy Sabino Nicholas Jason
Dolan
that's okay Jason guys if it's so cool
via mitotic Carter love dress still a
good amount of time
Britney Graham alright guys shouts out
to the patrons who showed up new Raj
Jason Dolan Erik horseman Lynnae anybody
who I didn't see who's he my colorful
Colorado ah did you did you [ __ ]
yourself over myself over man alright if
you don't if you if you can't love both
of us no you can not like me just um
just don't comment it throughout the
watch see you guys happy new year we'll
we'll post the venom reaction in the
morning man I last year was [ __ ] it's
tough yeah I really hate all of our
viewers say it all over I really hate
them all I'm not grateful for any of
this I'm just glad it's finally over
yep and that we could be alone
yep alone do you want to see my butthole
I don't know why you're waiting to see
your butthole for a long time I was
nervous I am yourself you're more open
than either of us maybe if you you know
we should go live again and maybe if you
show your bunghole will get even more
super chats people will support your
current - we gotta get sense an older
woman getting naked on Saturdays are
just doing videos and letting ad rep and
you pay for everything are over yeah
now the audience ask you directly we're
gonna download OBS and do all of our
reactions live I think that's what's the
future of this of this YouTube [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] are we still on what are you oh
here oh god turn it off after we send
those our ass